je vous en ai parlé il ya quelques jours
le xiaomi mis neuf ça c'est hyper cool
j'avais vraiment hâte de le recevoir il
est là enfin il est là voilà ça c'est le
chien aux mille 2009
il est franchement hyper intéressant
déjà lors de la présentation à la
conférence de presse la veille de
l'ouverture du mwc
je trouvais vraiment intéressant et
franchement je trouve très intéressant
ce chiot mini 9
il a des points très positifs il a aussi
des points négatifs on va donc listé les
raisons pour lesquelles il faut acheter
ce chien 8,9 et les raisons pour
lesquelles il faut passer à côté et au
final au bout du bout en fin de compte
in fine et est-ce qu'il vaut le coup oui
non
[Musique]
deux fichiers au mythe arrivé l'année
dernière en europe d'abord en espagne en
france et puis ils font des ti ils sont
extrêmement agressif en termes de prix
ils sont un positionnement tarifaire
avec une marge qui pas plus de 5% ce qui
leur permet d'avoir des produits qui
sont extrêmement bien placé et en plus
de ça l'idée de xiaomi c'est d'aller
vraiment proposer des produits avec les
dernières technologies tarifs défiant
toute concurrence est là dans cette
gamme me on est on également dans la
gamme mx avec le mx3 que je vous ai
présenté il n'y a pas très longtemps et
il y aura d'autres produits va y avoir
un autre produit qui va arriver d'ici
quelques jours on va en reparler dont je
vous invite à vous abonner et rester
connectés et justement aujourd'hui je
vous parle de ce mineur parce que ce
mineur il rassemble plein de points
positifs il est vraiment hyper
intéressant il est franchement cool le
mieux quand même c'est de vous le
montrer directement comme ça vous serez
vraiment le coche pas la première chose
que je vous propose c'est de regarder un
petit peu cette boîte alors bon allez
sympa côté un peu flashy
ce joli 9 qui flashent bon après c'est
une botte de smartphones c'est pas grave
c'est pas complètement dingue
à l'intérieur vous allez retrouver up
design by xiaomi c'est beau c'est
élégant c'est sympa alors ce qui est
sympa à l'intérieur c'est que vous ayez
à trouver ici
de quoi ouvrir votre tiroir de cartes
sim à l'adaptateur usb c'est jack qui
trouvent là parce que oui sur votre
smartphone vous n'avez absolument pas de
prise jack
bon ça c'est dommage qu'un des points
négatifs mais vous en parlais tout à
l'heure vous retrouvez une petite coque
de protection qui est là bon sera pas
forcément la plus belle la plus jolie
en tout cas une fois de plus c'est bien
qu'elle soit là et c'est bien que firmi
penser à la m on retrouve votre blog de
recharge un câble usb usb c est
normalement des petits écouteurs moi
c'est un modèle de démocrate a été prêté
par shiomi
donc je n'ai pas à l'intérieur de ma
boîte voilà globalement pour cette boîte
alors parlons du smartphone en lumens
moi je trouve que franchement il est
super sympa on retrouve cette petite
encoche goutte d'eau ça rappelle un peu
les design qu'on a depuis fin d'année
d'aimer 18 c'est pas hyper
révolutionnaire mais ça marche bien un
petit haut parleur qui est toujours bien
caché bien profilée un écran qui
occupent 90 7% de la face avant tout
petit menton débord qui sont très
discret en du point de vue de la face
avant franchement c'est sympa je vous
parlais de l'écran dans quelques
secondes
l'arrière alors vous avez un smartphone
qui tout en verre corning gorilla glass
6 à l'avant à l'arrière
hop maintenant qu'on peut lui reprocher
se font toujours cette fameuse trace de
doigt sur un dos en verre c'est normal
bon il n'y a rien de bien déconner
dessus de toute façon c'est un dock il
faut protéger si vous voulez qui dure un
peu dans le temps crypte module photo à
la verticale le flash l'écriture me vous
avez un smartphone qu'il y ait regardé
si vous le voyez qu'il légèrement
incurvé donc ça c'est assez cool du coup
on a une prise en main qui est vraiment
bien un smartphone qui est pas très
glissant ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle alors une fois de plus à l'est
je pense m'être une coque de protection
alors que côté glissant vous allez
passer un peu côté mais ça c'est
franchement très très très très sympa
vous avez ici de boutons de volume
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'état vous
allez voir paramétrable il ya des choses
à faire avec ses coûts il faut le dire
quelques instants micro haut parleurs
ici de recharge en usb tilt c'est son
côté un bouton google assistant qui est
ajoutée votre tiroir de cap cime
pommette de cartman aux cimes pas
d'extension microsd
vous avez ici de l'infrarouge un petit
micro ici pour la réduction de bruit
point qui est intéressant et nous en ait
une protection envers ici au niveau de
votre caméra arrière
c'est le verre saphir l'idée c'est que
ça n'aille pas rayer on va te sens qu'il
dépasse alors en fonction de ce que vous
allez mettre ici en coque de protection
sera plus ou moins bien intégrés mais si
vous le posez comme ça sur une table le
but c'est que ça n'aille pas le fro
texans n'avaient pas le rayer alors avec
ce verre saphir normalement ça vous le
protège je me suis pas amusé à la faute
et pendant des heures pour m'en rendre
compte mais bon sur ce principe je crois
sur parole
autre point qui est rigolo vous avez un
petit à l'autre couleur ou temps des
caméras là ça c'est assez rigolo bon
c'est un peu un point de détail mais
d'un autre côté vous quand on voit que
les smartphones se ressemblent tous de
plus en plus avec des tripes le module
photo c'est bien fait cette petite
différenciation alors là c'est pas le
modèle de plus sexy gelé en noir vous
l'avez aussi dans un espèce de dégrader
holographique rose ou alors bleus ils
sont beaucoup plus joli
malheureusement dans les modèles de prêt
il y avait que ça donc j'ai pris ce
combiné en tout cas je suis vraiment
content de pouvoir l'avoir et vous le
présenter dès aujourd'hui bon le design
est sympa c'est pas du tout là dessus
qu'on va se baser pour je dirais
trancher est ce qu'il fallait sur ce
smartphone you know qui est notre point
et notamment l'écran on a un écran qui
est signée samsung écran amoled 2340 par
1080 pixels cdu fhd plus à 403 pixels
par pouce avec un diagonale de 6,39
pouces ratio 19.59
m au delà du côté spec du côté grand
écran joly ce qui est vraiment bien et
ce qui est très sympa que cet écran
c'est qu'il est vraiment d'une
excellente qualité pour regarder vos
vidéos pour regarder deux contenus
multimédia pour jouer pour surfer sur
internet il est cool
alors j'ai un seul point faut faire un
petit peu gaffe je vous invite à aller
dans l'affichage je vous invite la lead
en contraste des couleurs et à mettre
vos couleurs sur chaud parce que par
défaut c'est un petit peu plus bleue
pour passer sur chaud c'est légèrement
plus jaune ça va être moins agressif
pour vos yeux en restant en contraste
automatique pour moi c'est un bon
compromis alors après vous pouvez aussi
aller sur les contrastes par défaut ça
va vous le rendre un peu plus jeunes par
contre ça va vraiment adoucir les
contrastes personnellement je préfère le
contraste automatique la couleur chaude
je trouve que là on a un bon compromis
encore de multimédia je trouve que
franchement l'écran est super sympa
alors hop vous venez krupp et un peu
dans votre image en fonction de la vidéo
vous et regardez je trouve ça pas mal on
à la toute petite goutte d'eau qui
dépassera côté c'est pas très très grave
même en jouant dans des jeux comme plj
absolument qu'une hâte en salle à
rebours l'agefi qu'au début de la partie
mais il apparaît en train de faire
canarder et que je vais me faire allumer
que dans cinq secondes je suis mort
salak pas c'est clean
est ce qu'on pourra était de chuter
comme un lapin s'il vous plaît
maintenant il ya un truc un peu dommage
c'est que vous avez que un seul
haut-parleur juste là alors il n'y a
quand même suffisamment le fond ça
marche pas mal
donc de ce point de vue là ça va c'est
pas dégueulasse mais c'est vrai que sur
un smartphone comme ça on aurait pu
s'attendre à avoir des haut parleurs
stéréo l'a714 par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans votre boîte
vous avez un petit accessoire pour mieux
brancher un casque dessus vous avez une
critique qui est pas dégueulasse après
lorsque vous le poussez fort une fois de
plus pour c'est pas forcément font parce
que vous allez vous rendre sourd il va
avoir tendance à tordre un petit peu
moyen plus à un autre point que je
remarque vous conseille d'utiliser les
quadeurs pour me à paramétrer parce que
le son est pas mal il est un peu trop
prononcé dans les médiums il faut bien
le creuse un petit peu vers un kilo 901
kilos personnellement j'utilise apple
musique de rappel musique vous
allez dans vos réglages vous allez dans
égaliseur et dans un coleader il faut le
casser un petit peu aussi alors ici
c'est du 910 hertz mais d'une manière
générale je n'ai cassé un petit peu le
médium vous laisser leur est plate et
vous allez vraiment récupéré en qualité
audio en termes de performances ça va on
a un qualcomm snapdragon 855 derrière si
giga de ram soit 64 giga de stockage
soit 128 giga de stockage dans les deux
cas non extensible donc réfléchissez
vraiment avant de l'acheter pour choisir
votre configuration est ce que vous avez
besoin de 64 gigas est-ce que vous avez
besoin de 128 giga personnellement le
vul prix gérait tout de suite sur 128
gygax surtout si vous faites beaucoup de
photos vidéos en 4k si vous mettez
beaucoup de musique plier un moment ça
risque de coincer et il obtient le très
joli score de 374 1783 surtout tout
autant vous dire que là franchement ça
marche à tartines vous êtes tranquilles
en plus ce qui est cool c'est que ces
postes personne qui va chauffer lorsque
vous avez utilisé dans des sessions de
jeu un peu plus poussé parlons justement
l'autonomie c'est toi qui me faisait un
petit peu peur sur le papier 3300
milliards terreur matri ça me paraissait
pas complètement dingue surtout vu la
diagonale de l'écran après j'imagine
très clairement on peut chez home il va
pas nous faire n'importe quoi des leurs
qui nous met une batterie de trois mille
trois cent millions terreur avec cette
machine là c'est parce que derrière ça
tourne c'est complètement optimisé
vous allez le garder une journée vous
attendez pas à le garder deux jours ou
alors à ce moment là vous ne l'utilisez
pas beaucoup mais sur un usage standard
en regardant des vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux d'écouter de la musique et une
tension quelques applis une journée
franchement ça tiendra au delà ça
commence à être un petit peu plus
compliqué à côté de ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez un blog
de recharge rapide donc à peu près une
heure voire un peu plus vous allez le
recharger à 100% ça c'est franchement
cool vous pouvez acheter en plus un
chargeur sans fil charger 20 watts pour
recharger rapidement ça franchement
c'est assez cool du point de vue l'ol on
tourne sur me why 10 qui tourne sur un
android 9 paille alors après on aime ou
on n'aime pas me voit il n'y a pas de
tiroirs d'application après vous avez
toujours la possibilité de changer votre
lunch hearst une fois vous êtes dépasse
celui là mais si vous voulez vraiment ce
smartphone c'est complètement possible
et quelques paramètres qui sont un peu
sympa notamment au niveau de l'affichage
vous pouvez mettre le mode nuit ça
voulait tout smartphone en noir
retrouvez votre petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales ici qui est assez
rapide c'est pas tout le plus dense du
monde on retrouve vraiment le capteur
d'empreintes digitales comme ce qu'on
avait avec le one pucistes et le match
d'impro ça marche mais est-ce que j'ai
du mal à comprendre c'est que vu qu'on
dragons 855 pourquoi est ce qu'ils nous
ont pas mis dessus un capteur
d'empreintes digitales à ultrasons c'est
israël est derrière techno surtout
lorsque vous avez le doigt mouillé ça
marcherait et là par contre c'est pas le
cas après vous avez une autre
possibilité pouvait venir déverrouiller
directement avec votre visage c'est le
fun hoc pour que facebook marche vous
devez changer les paramètres de votre
smartphone au niveau de la région vous
devez passer en a et là ça marche ça
marche très très bien j'étais en face et
déverrouille directement c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est beaucoup plus
simple et beaucoup plus rapide entre
port qui est sympa pouvait venir
personnaliser vos boutons le bouton pour
allumer par exemple jaupitre deux fois
dessus et hop ça va mal lu mais
l'appareil photo souvenir paramétrer ça
vous venez dans vos paramètres
supplémentaires de votre système vous
allez ensuite d'un raccourci des boutons
et des gestes et à vous allez pouvoir
choisir lancer l'appareil photo faire
une capture fin voilà vous avez pas mal
de petites choses pas mal de petits
raccourcis ça franchement ça c'est cool
autre point qui est très bon sur
smartphone et pas des moindres c'est la
partie photo vidéo vous avez un triple
capteur photo à l'arrière ça ne vous
aura pas échappé les tripes le capteur
ça devient je dirais de plus en plus
courant parce que en termes d' usage
c'est à cette agression ce qu'on peut
faire avec vous avez donc un capteur
principal c'est la fameuse caméra de
sony lit-et-mixe 586 j'en ai déjà parlé
notamment sur le honor vue ou 20 c'est
une caméra 48 mégapixels ce qui va se
passer notamment au niveau de la photo
de nuit ça vous prendre quatre gros
pixels pour faire un seul mais mes gros
pixels pour capter plus de lumière et ça
vous restituera une image 12 mégapixels
vous allez donc avoir des photos plus
précises plus jolie voulait pouvoir
zoomer de danse sont avant qualité on
vole un peu sur le principe entre
guillemets l'adn de cette caméra 48
mégapixels 7 sony mx 5 186 alors au delà
vous passez un peu le côté un peu
technique derrière cette caméra se
permettra d'avoir des photos qui sont
biens de bonne qualité et même la nuit
que vous avez une deuxième caméra ça
téléobjectif 12 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.2
l'idée avec cette caméra que si vous
allez pouvoir effectivement venir jouer
avec un zoom optique x 2 et vous allez
aussi avoir un zoom numérique faut 10
bon ça je vous recommande pas parce que
tout de suite vous allez récupérer
beaucoup de bruit sur les pixies et ça
va être dégueulasse ça on oublie et on
si vous avez troisième usages c'est une
caméra grand angle de 16 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.2 un grand-angle 210 7
degrés en gros ce qu'il faut bien
retenir avec cette caméra là
hier si vous êtes pour faire des photos
un peu classique de bonne qualité de
jour comme de nuit vous allez pouvoir
venir zoom et lorsque vous avez
suffisamment lumière donc sur des photos
de jour et vous allez pouvoir lorsque
vous voulez faire du paysage où vous
avez plein de monde à mettre sur une
photo vous pouvez le faire grâce au
grand-angle c'est le trois usages
principaux
après ce qui est très marrant c'est que
lorsque vous allez prendre des photos en
mode portrait par défaut votre
smartphone va faire avec la caméra
téléobjectif c'est très bizarre
là je suis en mode portrait nativement
je me retrouve sur la caméra zoom
optique
la preuve mais sur le mode photo
classique up caméra fois deux voiliers
mode portrait ça met directement dessus
et pour passer sur la caméra standard il
faut que j'appuie là c'est le mode corps
complet le mode portrait fonctionne
vachement bien regarder le détourage
alors là je vais vraiment poussé à fond
j'ai fait exprès de deux mètres
couverture la plus petite possible pour
avoir le meilleur flou le détourage et
franchement complètement incroyable ça
détour super bien il ya des petits
défauts de détourage mais sont
extrêmement minime ici bon ça après ça
vient du soc derrière mais franchement
le boulot est vraiment très très bien
fait ça manque légèrement de précision
au niveau des doigts mais franchement
sur une photo que vous allez regarder
comme ça il a j'ai vraiment exprès en
poussant d'ouverture à fond c'est
extrêmement bluffant ça marche très très
bien et ça franchement c'est hyper cool
ça c'est des photos qui sont prises avec
les modes corps entier et lorsque vous
utilisez le mode classique et voyez tout
de suite ça va venir vous mais il faut
un peu s'habituer parce que bon voilà
c'est pas ces pages et à l'avant vous
avez une caméra de sel fiva mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 2.0 qui marche
plutôt pas mal et après vous avez quand
même avec des photos qui sont très
sympas ça c'est une photo que le capteur
de 48 mégapixels en devenir zoom est
dedans sans perdre vraiment en précision
regardez là on repère franchement bien
les épices ça va c'est franchement cool
l'enac la caméra fois deux déjà les
couleurs sont pas exactement les mêmes
et là avec le grand-angle la même chose
avec des fleurs ça c'est la caméra
standard l'ouzoum x 2 et là la partie
grand-angle pareil avec ses deux fleurs
photos standard je peux venir zoom et je
vais récupérer du détail franchement
c'est pas mal du tout la zumba x 2 hélas
le grand-angle voilà je peux vous le
faire plusieurs fois
photo normale une fois deux grand-angle
les photos sont franchement de bonne
qualité il ya un très beau rendu il ya
ses limites un moment faut pas non plus
trop trop venir zoomer jeunesse locaux
dans l'absolu franchement c'est plutôt
bien et pour la partie vidéo pour filmer
jusqu'à 4
à 60 images par seconde il sera bien
meilleur en photo qu'en vidéo mais dans
l'absolu pour faire quelques souvenirs
partagés sociaux que je vous conseille
dans la partie photo c'est devenir
désactiver le mode beauté qui va venir
un peu trop vous lisser la peau moi
personnellement je suis pas du tout fan
je préfère à côté un peu plus naturel
que ces artifices qui au final sont pas
géniaux qu'on résume un peu la situation
on a un smartphone avec un design qui
est élégant contemporain qui va bien on
a un écran d'excellente qualité qui est
très lumineux avec un bel équilibre des
couleurs et un contraste est très sympa
écran de bonne qualité un smartphone
très rapide avec le dernier sauf de
qualcomm le snapdragon 855 se complaît à
6 giga de ram
l'autonomie est franchement pas mal du
tout en gros on a smartphones qui belle
bête de compet
on a des capteurs photo qui marche très
bien le traitement logiciel est pas mal
attention si les images sont trop lisse
et faut venir faire un petit peu
rééquilibré aller gratter un peu dans
les paramètres mais dans l'absolu ce
smartphone est franchement hyper bien et
surtout coûte moins de 500 euros il est
donc hyper agressif en termes de prix
alors après il ya des choses que j'aime
un peu moins le fait que vous ayez juste
un haut parleur mono pad haut-parleurs
stéréo ça gâche un petit peu expérience
multimédia et je mets des grandes villes
mais quand je dis ça gâche au delà de ça
il ya quand même suffisamment de
puissance et si vous faisiez rajouter
votre petit adaptateur vous pouvez
mettre un casque avec une prise directe
ça fonctionne cette fois ci il ya un
truc que je regrette franchement c'est
que vu la qualité de smartphones vous
n'avez absolument aucune certification
contre l'eau et la poussière pas
certification ip67 pas de certification
ifs et 68 ça vraiment dommage pour un
smartphone qui vient jouer dans la cour
des grands amylie majorée d'une
certification ip67 je ne sais pas ce qui
va se passer si ce smartphone rencontre
de l'opa des petites deux buts de plus
mais s'il rencontre un verre d'eau
fraîche
j'aimerais pas tout cas je vais pas
faire le test donc bon c'est un petit
peu le trou qui m'embête
vous avez du bûto 5.0 vous avez du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé ça c'est
aussi cool
au final qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir
parce que ce smartphone il a des côtés
positifs des côtes et un peu plus
négatifs
est-ce qu'il est bien oui non alors je
vais très transparent avec vous si vous
cherchez un smartphone avec un rapport
qualité prix absolument incroyable c'est
une bête c'est franchement un excellent
smartphone j'ai absolument pas été déçu
et je pense que vous ne serez pas non
plus je trouve que le mineur est
vraiment
super rapport qualité prix on va pas
avoir les trucs les plus fous on va pas
avoir des gadgets en pas voir le slider
comme sur le mx3 mais par contre on va
avoir un smartphone super bien fabriqué
avec des super performance un très bel
écran ça je vous ai déjà tout dit voilà
joue je suis vraiment très satisfait je
ne peux que vous conseiller d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse vous avez le lien en
bas dans la description on va reparler
de shinobi très prochainement bon vous
pouvez vous abonner et si vous voulez
tout savoir sur les smartphones du
moment
les nouveautés ce qui sort ce qui arrive
quand comment vous avez la playlist
quelque part par ci par là
j'invite à les regarder et n'oubliez pas
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce qu'il vous plaît
ce mineur est ce que vous le trouver
intéressant est ce que vous avez
succombé est ce que vous pourriez
succomber vous marquez tout ça on en
parle ensemble nous en masse nous prenez
soin de vous ciao